you worry about a boy and a girl and
they both have two different parallel
stories going on and their can jump back
and forth between them
a young girl has been chosen for this
big honor that she finds out is actually
being sacrificed to a horrible monster
or the safer town and her stories about
choosing to break out of that
arrangement and then the boy has grown
up alone on a spaceship that takes care
of his every needs and creates
entertainment for him and takes care of
his food his health and everything that
he's all by himself out in space
human letter repair hexa pals as long as
that sounds I couldn't know I just
escaped the Navy's beast and now mom
chakra is going to either town you've
watched while you've been drifting
through the universe war has been raging
across the galaxy war between who
please unhook my underwear from the
branch sorry I'm not going anywhere near
your underwear I'm going to kill Bob
chopper shave are you going
it's not safe
why does a big company get to choose
what music I listen to or what movies i
watch TV shows are watching or if I get
to play
they can't do that anymore you can
choose so thanks everybody very much
you